[Music]  how is this possible  do you know what this place is  your mother angela she's our patient  i've been out of touch with her for  a very long time thank god  her mind is very active in the  simulation simulation  she went on a homicidal rampage  this is your chance to ask her why  mom carly you have to go  you have to go  guys please let me out can you hear me  are you sure that you haven't been  having any hallucinations outside of the  simulation  [Music]  [Applause]  demonic possession it could be real  i can't do this you won't end up like  your mother  the vatican has been funding a black ops  unit he's increased  like soldiers now that it's free  it won't stop coming for you  stop right there  [Music]